focus now on national parks with Sally
Jaramillo taking us to the Lake Mead
recreational area to show us why it is
the six most visited national park in
the entire country in the 1930s the
Hoover Dam was constructed and at that
time that actually transformed the
mighty Colorado River into Lake Mead
which is America's largest reservoir it
was 1935 when people started utilizing
the area for recreation so the National
Park Service helps the Bureau of
Reclamation manage the area of her
recreation and the area was known as the
Boulder Canyon National Recreation Area
Lake Mead spokeswoman Christy Vanover
says Lake Mead National Recreation Area
became the first National Recreation
Area in 1964 so the park is one and a
half million acres where the size of the
state of Delaware within those areas
you're also going to find campgrounds
launch ramps hiking trails and then we
have hundreds of miles of paved and
unpaved roads so people can do lots of
scenic driving as well we have multiple
developed campgrounds and you can do
anything from camping with by pitching a
tent or bring in your RV and do full
hookups with showers and all sorts of
things for you the best part for only
twenty five dollars you and your family
can enjoy the area for a week there's
also services in the park like boat
rentals so if you don't have your own
boat you can rent a boat you can rent a
kayak up stand-up paddleboard even a
house there for out-of-town visitors
Lake Mead is not something expected in
the middle of the desert
I think visitors are always happy when
they come here you can't help but just
be you know fielding that joy when the
Sun is beating on your face and you get
the reflection of the water it is just
absolutely beautiful I don't know it
feels like we're closer to God sunny had
a meal
reporting from Lake Mead an annual pass
that covers both Lake Mead in Lake
Mohave area is $45 for the year